can I get a drumroll please thank you
Bob
Bob is my my in-house drummer doing a
very good job right now
I should really use you more often Bob
to be honest ladies and gentlemen it is
my privilege to introduce your today to
the newest member of the is so cooling
crew oh dear he's sleeping very pleased
fully right now listen we're gonna have
you go on camera now you won't even
remember it I promise
introducing Gideon yay oh he doesn't he
doesn't want to be involved that's fine
I'll put you down I'll just show you on
here quickly here we go look at him look
at him sleeping so peacefully now at a
glance
Gideon may appear to be a relatively
normal looking cat but unfortunately he
did come to us with a little bit of a
tragic backstory in a previous life
Gideon was a member of a gang of about
five different cats that lived on the
streets of East London just roaming
around grabbing scraps where they could
luckily forget Ian though the lovely
people that cats protection put us in
touch with an old lady who was feeding
him out of her back garden so we went
over to go and pick him up he was kind
of going a bit crazy when we went to
pick him up virtually he was like
climbing up the walls and he like
scratched the old lady accidentally we
think but she was like she was properly
bleeding even she was like I don't know
if you guys could handle this cat to be
honest but we believed in you didn't we
give you always haven't quite a bad
dream right now probably remembering
those bad times we did have a few
teething problems when we first brought
him home like he did spend the first two
days just hiding from us under the sofa
and it made me a bit sad but at the same
time humans are the most dangerous
animals on the planet like fair enough
that you would be a little bit
intimidated I would be scared in that
situation it was however slightly less
cool when Gideon decided to do his first
poop in our flat not in the litter box
that we provided for him but instead and
our sofa and he did a lot of wing under
there as well as a result of that
incident he did unfortunately have to
have his first bath on that second day
because he was soaked in his own poop
and urine he handled it pretty well
actually we were pretty terrified of
putting him in there like there he would
because we heard cats hate water
but Gideon's alright with it he said
he's a little bit different like that
special little snowflake as I like to
call
oh god this is so embarrassing I'm such
a dad oh it's embarrassing that I even
called myself a dad oh dear I just like
my can you know is that what it's like a
problem I mean what can I say he's had a
large impact on my life I am definitely
a cat person now I think I used to be
like full-on dog person and then I met
Emily and she kind of like she's such a
cat person that she kind of dragged me
in the middle somewhere and now that I
have Gideon I'm like yes this is the
animal for me it is kind of a weird term
though isn't it like it's only with cats
and dogs that people they love them so
much that they literally refer to
themselves as being a cat person but you
wouldn't say I am a fish person because
that's just weird isn't it I like
conjured up an image in my head of like
you know of a mermaid like a human fish
hybrid but with like cat people well now
I'm just kind of imagining like what
would be like to have cat people around
it would be nice if we had cat people
don't you think they'd probably be
alright um I think I'm just gonna end
that one there that kind of petered out
in niche I show you Gideon one more time
Oh buddy get away from me
I ain't gonna I don't know why that's
his voice don't put me on youtubes but
it's a hard voice to do you've just had
the almost imponderable joy of watching
Charlie is so cool like which makes you
like cool thank you very much for
watching if you'd like to watch an
hour's worth of me doing directors
commentaries of my short films with my
friends you can click up there and if
you'd like to see the first video on
Gideon's own YouTube channel you can
click down there I think I know which
one's gonna win out but I thought I'd
give you the option anyway okay that
that'll do video blog all done done the
video blog only took me a month